aujourd'hui on comptabilise plus de 2
millions 2,99 en europe
c'est l'équivalent de la population de
la lettonie entière près de trente mille
décès ont été enregistrés ces sept
derniers jours sur le continent européen
le sar skov de à une puissance de frappe
exponentielle en europe et les fêtes de
fin d'année approchant à grands pas les
différents gouvernements européens ont
dû faire des choix concernant les
réunions familiales et amicales
faisons un tour d'europe pour voir
ensemble quelles restrictions ont été
adoptées selon les pays
et quel est l'état qui a opté pour les
règles les plus strictes d'europe
la réponse à cette question vous la
trouverez en fin de vidéo est pour
l'instant
explications dans facture commençons
tout d'abord par l'allemagne qui compte
260 mille cas au total et près de 600
morts sur la journée seul du 8 décembre
et fight 10ème futur haut niveau la
mannschaft intensif mellitine sparano
de l'autre côté du rhin en gala merkel à
faire entrer l'allemagne dans un
confinement partiel pour plus de trois
semaines et les rendez-vous allant du 24
au 26 décembre ne seront possibles
contre membre de la très proche famille
finalement qui sont pourtant très
attachés à leur marché de noël en seront
privés et certains allemands ne se sont
pas laissé abattre et proposent leurs
produits en braille viennent pour cette
année exceptionnelle l'italie ne sera
plus à la botte de l'épidémie le premier
pays touché par la pandémie de kovy 19
en europe
comptant plus de 68 me more cherche à
éviter de se retrouver dans une
situation semblable à celle du mois de
mars
l'italie est un des seuls pays d'europe
à faire le choix de renforcer ces
restrictions pour les fêtes
en remettant en place en confinement
graduée jusqu'au 6 janvier ça lag et
atos dispose semaine d'autres elle est
jolie
puisqu'on joue harry hole in alsace de
la cour des comptes à jilin tel
territoire national et gujarat zones à
risque meggiorini fihri épreuve et
l'italie sera donc en rouge les 24 25 26
27 et 31 décembre
mais également les 1er 2 5 et 6 janvier
les italiens ne pourront sortir de chez
eux qu une seule fois par jour
sauf dérogation spéciale pour noël et le
nouvel an ils ne pourront indiquer que
deux convives chez eux
hors du cercle familial restreint qui
pourront être accompagnés de leurs
enfants de moins de 14 ans ou de
personnes handicapées irlande elle a
pris une direction opposée à celle des
italiens
rappelez-vous la république irlandaise
était la première à demander à ses
concitoyens de se confiner c'était le 21
octobre et les irlandais ont été des
conflits nés le 1er décembre sur le fil
colotto un pays dont le plan pour les
fêtes est assez détendue puisque les
voyages seront autorisés et une trêve de
noël du 18 décembre au 6 janvier a été
adopté pour permettre aux familles peu
importe leur âge et le nombre d'enfants
ne se réunit seule une limite de trois
foyers réunis en même temps leur sera
imposé bien que la situation en suisse
se dégrade avec plus de 5000 morts dus
aux coronavirus 350 7000 cas recensés
pour une population de 8 5 millions
d'habitants
la suisse opte pour une restriction
étonnant pour endiguer la seconde vague
de colette 19
de l'autre côté du jura les suisses
pourront skier mais ils n'auront plus le
droit de chanter cette interdiction
s'applique en dehors du cercle familial
et des écoles
les suisses ne pourront donc pas chanter
leur d'offices religieux et enfin la
belgique qui était le pays européen le
plus touché par l'épidémie de colette 19
avec près de 20 mille nouveaux cas au
pic de la deuxième vague est aussi le
pays qui a opté pour les limitations les
plus strictes al'approche de noël
de noël sera différente que d'habitude
elle rassembla par noël précédent
nous fêterons dans notre foyer nous le
fait trop d'une manière dans un comité
plus restreint d'une manière plus
gentille cette année les familles belges
ne pourront pas se retrouver même en
nombre réduit puisque une seule personne
extérieure d'un foyer pourra rejoindre
la table et de noël le premier ministre
alexander de croo à augmenter ce chiffre
à 2 personnes pour les belges vivant
seules l'exécutif a appelé ses citoyens
à faire preuve de sérieux
le ministre de l'intérieur and all his
verlinden a également annoncé que si
nécessaire la police sonnera aux portes
à noël la france elle se place plus ou
moins en milieu de classement un couvre
feu de 20h à 6h a été instauré et ce
même pour le nouvel an une dérogation
sera fait pour noël afin de permettre
aux français de fêter le réveillon aux
côtés de six adultes l'après un sondage
ifop réalisé pour aude hérault en 2019
les français passer noël au côté de but
cinq adultes
cette année 77 % respecteront les
recommandations du gouvernement et
s'attableront à 5 personnes en moyenne
[Musique]